hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play the great
work I'm actually recording this at
about eleven thirty five so it's very
dark in my room now and it's actually
probably the latest I've ever recorded a
game so let's give it a try we're going
into the forest does that dust on my
screen or did I see something I'm not a
quite sure anyway I think I'm hearing
some wolves or something in the
background I keep thinking I see who
okay the darkness is after me
oh man there's definitely a better woods
than I've seen in a lot of hamnida games
hey huh oh boy go around I can't go
around those bushes it's just too thick
I can't push them away with my spindly
little arms alright I guess I'm not
going that way where am I going into the
maze-like bushes that's a good sign
I don't have enough oil oh I have full
oil did I get full oil where am I going
I don't know I'm just wandering into the
woods this cannot be correct
I found a boulder with a cross on top
why what's the deal who who's that who's
that who's it and I don't know where I'm
supposed to be going but it's definitely
not here oh why does it feel like
slender uh where am I going on lost I
completely lost the trail
and now I'm just kind of wandering into
the woods it's probably bad
prolly prolly
okay so uh-huh what are you ah
you're blocked up it doesn't help me oh
maybe I can move that down
aha like a boss
this was a mistake this is a mistake
this is a big mistake
uh-oh
got a stairwell oh boy
who's bad this bad is bad oh come on
what is this
shut up kid
is this what to be no Maj the SCP Oh hmm
be because in SCP oa7 be there's a
stairwell and there's a kid at the
bottom that people reported that they
could hear and I could hear a little kid
ha ha oh I thought I saw something oh oh
oh this totally is this totally is this
definitely I know MA chère CPI tempie uh
uh-huh
ended thank the cage his horror his
shard hummed his hard shoved with energy
when he started the machine my hards
shaman RI okay everything seemed to be
progressing well but without the other
shards he could not know if the machine
could repair the arm it wonder where
they had gone and curse Lam
ah oh like hell you're gonna get me I'm
too fast for you
oh this looks familiar it's made of an
extremely strong steel not just strong
steel excessively in strong steel
I said no alcohol no no do good the
knife brah haha you [ __ ] you [ __ ] ah
you got are you [ __ ] oh I should have
known that extremely it's stuck well I
wish I had my knife
well piece of ball Nino goodness
gracious is just stupid well here's a
hidey hole for when I'll eventually need
to run away which I'm sure it's going to
happen glad they gave me some oil it's
made of extremely strong steel oh I was
close so close to what close to what
Bree Bree will you close to you okay ah
it's just here let's see what's inside
huh good you love down annamund plenty
of Tyndale boxes no oil though I guess
save my thought but they gave me enough
oil why do I deserve more sorry
something's checking my throat
haha alright
sorry it's dark in here but I'm trying
to conserve oil I don't want to be
spending it when I can kind of make out
the outlines of what's in these rooms I
don't have enough need more oil need ah
lovely
hi I don't think I can open these hi
this is what thought something in there
nope nothing okay that's about all
that's in here was that hint no key no
nothing that I needed nothing important
quest related there seems to be a pile
of goop under there that's about it
all right hit it out let us go we've got
one more part of this quadrant to
explore right here there's something on
here that's needed hey look a knife
maybe that can replace the one you broke
talking to the game not you guys I would
never yell at you you all know that I
love you so much okay alright see got a
dead dog's head why do I need a dog's
head live um got an oil lamp dead bunny
dead bird dead goop did rats okay
nothing important here nothing nothing
Wow
why am I here was the point of all this
look at all this opium man
why am I here what is my purpose in life
Bernie - well this was eventful
I I have nothing there's nothing there
for me what am I supposed to do haha can
I use his item this way
there's something in the mementos no I
haven't gotten a memento in a while okay
there was nothing in here let me listen
like that oh that's blue too huh how
fanciful some sort of schematic here I
don't know nothing on the walls nothing
secret nothing to explore oh sorry kid
no she said something stuck in my throat
all day don't know why see you like one
of these at least oh yeah that's a lot
of light a screw you
Oh pitch blackness all right there's got
to be something in these rooms that is
important a switch maybe like in the
very first level I remember there was a
switch up against like the walls or
something it was really tucked away but
scouring every inch of this room it
doesn't look like that is the case no
books
another big Potter opium here removable
jars but nothing important to the cause
just yet okay looks like a negative big
Johnny
alright here we go maybe something in
this one some wants to keep a secret
from me
look you could hide for me caribou gonna
waste all my oil herro update oh final
search of the darkness okay there was
absolutely nothing here correct correct
tear it well I got nothing I am lost
like a little aha
I knew those some there's another chest
of a half aha I'm gonna hammer the [ __ ]
out of that door wow I am a good thing
I'm so strong it's still it's too strong
no it cannot be
ah well [ __ ] him I do with this I have
the hammer now what do I do with the
hammer
what do i do wait a minute can I move
this or was that your sister oh I
thought maybe I can move that dresser
never mind okay there must be an oh
whoops I almost miss that the chisel was
right there you're chipper oh wow that
makes things much easier this should
suffice for my purposes big ah hey would
my dagger broke I got [ __ ] all for tools
and this steel is extremely strong maybe
maybe I shouldn't be looking at the
steel maybe instead I should be looking
at the walls to the sides of this deal
maybe there's a weak spot in the walls
nope there's good thought but apparently
that's not the case
haha it's still so strong Oh still so
strong okay there's got to be something
else in one of these rooms that I am
missing error floor I will explore it oh
yeah I remember I almost forgot about
that holy hell
key [ __ ] all that would have been so
easy to forget I'm surprised I didn't
get a momento about that it was such a
small detail but I am a baller and I'm
getting in here with thumb a kind of a
decent amount of oil whoo okay all right
ignore that guy we commend you for your
daring escape from London it took two
bravery and wit twists they'd be able to
escape from us the remaining two hulls
have heads removed to a more secure
location and we trust that you have
already found that you can no longer
escape we would have rather avoided your
death but you have let a little choice
if there is anybody to left in your own
life now you with us avoid a war more
riling death we will return at a later
date collect your remains to give you a
proper burial rest assured knowing that
our holy master more rain will play
your sacrifice there are wealthier Lord
Hawk okay so maybe Samuel is not a bad
guy here alright so I'm obviously not
you're a creepy son of a [ __ ] aren't
you
okay I'm obviously not gonna end my own
life [ __ ] what's the point of that just
to get in there and get that note if so
that was an extremely silly maneuver way
to have a paddle of what ah
methinks I need to do something with
this now I have pushed dear padlocks
what woo ah
balls ah I'll padlock you in
I'll padlock me in here haha you can't
get me if I oh there's a dumb is dumb no
I was supposed to trap him in here come
on anybody
oh ah oh god I gotta getta getta getta
getta getta yeah yeah get it go around
all the way all the way your honor doc
ah oh I get it
first drop inch first Robin yeah [ __ ]
you
oh my god
okay the music's still pretty intense I
don't know what I'm supposed to do
though maybe go out the other way
Oh yup let's keep moving let's not look
back ah now look back going back Oh
balls
oh hello whoa I'm being sucked in
when Maureen asked for the builders to
expand the tunnels underneath minimag
for his research Ernst Albrecht had many
questions
Maureen placated them easily enough as
he had ad dies to the family for a
decade he only hoped they wouldn't
notice the freshly disturbed grave in
their cemetery
ah wait why huh okay all right doing all
right here well now all right got a
little journal out here it seems a
monstered was destroyed but where am I
now I seem to be in an underground
tunnel of some sort I did a damn damn
fine job there most excellent sir why
thank you yes and that is officially all
the time I have now so thank you all so
much for watching let me know what
you're thinking what I should do in the
next part in the comments below you're
helping me get through this custom
campaign so thanks again and as always I
will see you in the next video bye-bye
don't